نحن نتواجد الان في مدرسه غازي الشوه هنا
في بيت حانون اقصى شمالي القطاع هنا كانت
تتواجد قوات الاحتلال واليات الاحتلال لكن
بعدما تراجعت وانسحبت بالكامل من هذه
المنطقه ومن بيت حانون عاد الاهالي للبحث
عن منازلهم لمحاوله الاستمرار في الحياه
لكن فوجئوا بتدمير كامل لجميع المنازل
ولجميع البيوت وتدمير كامل ايضا للبنيه
التحتيه هنا في بيت حنون وللشوق والطرقات
تمت تدميرها بالكامل احنا تقريبا بعد نزوح
ما يقارب 90 يوم خارج مدينه بيت حنون بعد
ما عرفنا بانسحاب قوات الاحتلال من
المدينه وتراجع اي جينا على المدينه نشوف
بيوتنا نشوف سبل الحياه نرجع لبيوتنا لكن
الحمد لله رب العالمين ما لقينا بيوت ما
لقينا شوارع ولا بنيه تحتيه لا كهرباء ولا
ميه لكن الحمد لله لقينا مدرسه غاز الشوه
يمكن تقريبا هي المدرسه الوحيده في بيت
حنون او كمان مدرسه معها بس
صالحات للسكن وجانا لها وهينا قعدنا وهينا
بنحاول انه ندبر سبل الحياه اللي هي الميه
الكهرباء بدنا يعني شيء من مقاومات الحياه
وهي زي ما انت شايف المدرسه كلها انتلت
ولسه في ناس بتزايد قاعد الاعداد وبترجع
الناس شوي شويه بتدبر
حي احنا احنا زي ما انت شايف هي طاقه
شمسيه مدبرين حالنا بالكهرباء قصه
الكهرباء بشحن بطاريات بنضو لدات بشحن
جوالاتنا بالنس من الخبز هي الاخوات بتخبز
على افران الطينه مدبره امورها الطبيخ على
النار برضه اي حاجه من الارض بنجيب خبيزه
بنجيب حمصيص بنجيب بنخبز وبناكل بنطبخ
وبناكل والحمد لله رب العالمين خلص احنا
رجعنا لبيت حنون وحظنا في بيت حنون وفيش
نزوح من بيت حمون باذن الله ان شاء الله
رب العالمين واحنا بالنسبه لنا يعني نزوح
ل 90 يوم كان يعني رغم عنا يعني مش بخطر
رغم عنا ولكن الحمد لله هينا رجعنا لبيت
حنون رغم دمار بيت حنون احنا حنظل في بيت
حانون هكذا هو المشهد هنا في بيت حانون
وهكذا هو صمود المواطنين وصمود النازحين
رغم ما اصابهم من دمار ومن معاناه
واستمرار للمعاناه يوما بعد يوم انس
الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه